Este es otro problema que me envió Cortachio.
Me gustan mucho estos problemas,
pues a primera vista parecen simples y de hecho, las soluciones son bastante simples,
pero la aparente falta de información que proporcionan hace que sea difícil inclusive,
empezar a abordar estos problemas.
Te voy a ser honesto, con este problema
en un principio me atoré
hasta que me di cuenta qué es lo que
piden y cómo encontrarlo.
Así que en este problema tenemos a Bev, que
toma el tren a casa a las 4:00,
llegando a la estación a las 6:00.
Todos los días, manejando a la misma velocidad,
su esposo la recoge en la estación. Un día ella toma el tren una hora antes y llega a las 5:00.
Su esposo sale de casa para recogerla
a la misma hora usual... a la misma hora usual,
ese día entonces su esposo sale de casa para
recogerla a la hora usual...
aquí hay algo por considerar,
¿a qué hora sale usualmente el esposo?
Veamos cómo está la cosa.
Esto es lo que normalmente ocurre,
lo voy a hacer en verde.
Normalmente ella llega a las 6:00,
aquí lo tenemos, llega a la estación a las 6:00,
yo no sé si esto que sale a las 4:00 nos sirve de algo
y el marido, llega a la estación justo
cuando ella está llegando,
así que para encontrarla en la estación
el tiene que viajar...
no sé... bueno, déjame ponerlo de esta manera
porque así es como lo estoy visualizando,
así es como estoy pensando...
así es que ahí llega él,
a las 6:00 de la tarde también llega él,
¿y a qué hora salió?
¿cuánto tiempo le tomó?
Digamos entonces que le toma
"t" minutos llegar ahí, le toma un tiempo
"t" que desconocemos.
Si llega a las 6:00, quiere decir que salió a las 6:00 menos "t", si "t" es 30 minutos,
salió a las 5:30, si "t" es 1 hora salió a las 5:00...
así es que sale... sale... a las 6:00...
menos "t"...
cualesquiera que sean las unidades de "t",
la recoge y qué hace, la lleva de regreso
a casa, ¿correcto?
así que regresa a casa...
déjame hacerlo con una línea más delgada...
se regresa a casa, suponemos que no se pierde
el tiempo cuando la está recogiendo en la estación,
ella simplemente sube al coche,
el auto gira y emprenden el viaje de regreso,
así es que regresan y esto les lleva el mismo
tiempo "t" ¿correcto?
Entonces, ¿a qué hora llegan de regreso?
Si salió "t" minutos antes de las 6:00,
llegó a la estación y regresó después de los
mismos "t" minutos, entonces llega...
llega...
llega... a las 6:00 más "t",
¿y cuánto tiempo empleo en la ida y en la vuelta?
Bueno, si salió a las 6:00 menos "t"
y regresó a las 6:00 más "t", hace la diferencia, 6
más "t" menos 6:00 "-t"
los 6:00 se cancelan "t" menos "-t" es "2t",
le tomo "2t" minutos,
esto es obvio si le tomo "t" minutos de ida y "t" minutos de regreso, en total le tomo "2t" minutos.
Hasta ahí vamos bien, ahora,
¿qué pasa en este día en particular?
Dice que el esposo sale de casa para recogerla a la hora usual, de nueva cuenta, él sale... él sale..
voy a hacer esto en rojo...
él sale...
él sale a las 6:00 menos "t", ¿correcto?
Y entonces, como ella llega temprano
le va a tomar menos tiempo, pues la va a encontrar en el camino y eso no lo vamos a etiquetar por el momento,
solo vamos a mostrar la gráfica,
ese día él viaja un tiempo menor,
pues ese día en particular ella llegó antes y tuvo
que caminar, eso es lo que nos están diciendo aquí,
que ella llegó antes a la estación,
llegó a las 5:00, por lo cual empezó a caminar
y se encontraron en el camino, así es que la
distancia que recorrió fue menor
y por tanto el tiempo empleado, también fue menor.
Y entonces, cualquiera que haya sido ese tiempo,
es el mismo que le toma de regreso.
Así es que, para el viaje de regreso,
le va a tomar el mismo tiempo,
exactamente el mismo tiempo.
¿Y qué nos dicen?
Se encuentran en el camino y llegan a casa
20 min. antes de lo usual.
Tenemos que normalmente llegan a las 6:00 más "t",
eso es lo usual, pero ahora van
a llegar 20 minutos más temprano,
así es que van a llegar a las 6:00 más "t" que es lo usual, menos 20, van a llegar 20 minutos antes.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el tiempo total de viaje
del marido ese día?
¿cuánto tiempo viajó ese día?
Básicamente él viajó, 20 minutos menos
del tiempo usual, sale al mismo tiempo y llega
20 minutos antes.
Si hacemos la resta de 6:00 más "t" menos
20 menos 6:00 menos "t", vamos a obtener,
"2t" menos 20, y eso es casi obvio, quizás
no tenía que haber dibujado esto,
podrías haber considerado que si "t" es el tiempo
que normalmente le toma en ir a la estación,
en un día normal le va a tomar de ida y de
vuelta "2t" minutos, el día de hoy
sale a la misma hora, llega 20 minutos antes por
lo cual le tomó "2t" menos 20.
¿Y esto cómo nos sirve?
Bueno, con esto podemos calcular
cuanto le toma en ir a recoger a su esposa, si el tiempo que le toma en ir y regresar
es "2t" menos 20, el tiempo para irla a recoger sería la
mitad de esto, es decir,
"t" menos 10 para ir y "t" menos 10 para regresar.
Así es que en esta ocasión,
le tomó 10 minutos menos para recogerla, así es que,
¿a qué horas la recogió?
Aquí tenemos la clave, normalmente cuando
le toma "t" minutos, él llega a las 6
en esta ocasión ella empezó a caminar porque llegó más temprano y él llega 10 minutos antes,
el marido la encuentra, 10 minutos
antes de lo que normalmente lo hace,
¿de acuerdo?
"t" menos 10, normalmente llega a las 6:00,
hoy llega 10 minutos antes.
Así es que se encuentran a las 5:50...
Bev y su marido se encuentran a las 5:50 y
la pregunta es,
¿Cuántos min. caminó Bev?...
¿Cuántos min. caminó Bev?
Recuerda, llegó una hora antes y llegó a
las 5:00, que fue cuando empezó a caminar,
ella llega a las 5:00 y empieza a caminar
y se encuentra a las 5:50,
así es que ella caminó 50 min.
Este es un problema muy interesante,
porque de alguna manera es un problema fácil, pero
por otro lado te dan información
que no sirve de nada, lo más evidente es este dato de
las 4:00 que no nos sirve absolutamente de nada,
es información innecesaria, pero lo
demás queda muy abstracto, no nos dan detalles,
pudimos calcular cuanto tiempo camina sin necesidad de saber la velocidad a la que ella camina
o la velocidad a la que maneja el esposo
o la distancia donde se encuentran
o la distancia de la estación a la casa, sin necesidad
de eso pudimos calcular cuanto tiempo camina.
En fin, interesantísimo problema,
gracias de nuevo a Cortachio.